con el lanzamiento de cinco proyectiles
desde la franja de gaza hacia el sur de
Israel los milicianos palestinos han
respondido esta madrugada a la muerte de
diez palestinos a manos de las fuerzas
israelíes recordemos que este jueves 9
murieron en el campo de refugiados de
llenín en la redada israelí más letal
que se ha visto en 20 años y otro más
durante una posterior protesta en la
ciudad de al-ram de ahí estos cohetes
que ni jamás ni la yihat islámica
Palestina u otros se han atribuido y que
no han causado daños ni víctimas pero
que sí fueron contestados por un ataque
de aviones de combate israelíes que
según el ejército de Israel destruyeron
un centro subterráneo de fabricación de
cohetes de jamás a este intercambio
militarmente desigual también se suma el
hecho de que la autoridad Palestina haya
suspendido la coordinación en seguridad
con Israel esto significa por ejemplo
que Israel no va a reportar sus
operaciones en cisjordania para que por
ejemplo se evacue la zona que las
fuerzas palestinas no comparti
información de sospechosos o prisioneros
palestinos y que no arrestarán a
personas buscadas por Israel entre
muchos otros aspectos no se sabe Por
cuánto tiempo la autoridad Palestina va
a mantener este corte de esta
comunicación si va a ser total o va a
ser parcial pues no es la primera vez y
en el pasado no logró sostener esta
medida como en 2020 que sólo dura unos
meses ante un plan de gobierno de
benjamine tan Yahoo de anexionar ciertas
partes de cisjordania pero nada de esto
augura un cese de la violencia con 30
palestinos muertos en solo 27 días y a
puertas de una visita del secretario de
estado estadounidense Anthony blinken